Why is DALL-E 3 better than DALL-E 2? Well,
maybe the difference between them is not so
visible from these two generated images,
but rather here. Why can DALL-E 3 create
so many details we have specified in the text
prompt? It’s mainly because DALL-E 3 trained
on better captions than DALL-E 2, but we do
not know every other technical improvement,
since this technical report from OpenAI does
not contain too many details about DALL-E 3,
as the authors kindly point out in
footnote 5 on page 10. In this video,
we will see what we know about DALL-E 3
and how a simple trick helped DALLE-3
become so much better at following
prompts than its predecessor.
But first, let's thank Gradient, the sponsor of
today's video! I've always wondered how a bank
or a hospital could use a large language model to
give capable answers about things that are stored
in their private databases especially since their
industries are so complex. Well, Gradient is here
to help. Gradient offers out-of-the-box industry
expert LLMs that come highly tuned for specific
industries like healthcare, financial services,
and compliance. Even more, through simple API
calls, you can finetune LLMs and combine it with
your own private data to improve the model's skill
and understanding of your organization. You can
also use Retrieval Augmented Generation where
the LLM can look up things in your proprietary
database while generating the answer. I know
industries like healthcare and finance are highly
regulated, so luckily Gradient is both SOC 2 and
HIPPA compliant, which is a great for the US.
But it's also great for the EU since Gradient is
GDPR compliant and you deploy within your private
environment, so your data never leaves you. Check
out Gradient in the link in description below!
Now, back to the video. DALL-E 3 is out. It is
a diffusion model that you can use as a ChatGPT
Plus user and through BingChat. Here is a short
timeline of how OpenAI progressed image generation
since 2021: January 2021 OpenAI released DALL-E 1
which generated images with an autoregressive
transformer, basically from top to bottom. The
pictures looked good but were small resolution
and without many details and also a bit blurry.
December 2021, they switched to diffusion models
with GLIDE that generate an image from noise step
by step. We have many previous videos about
diffusion models if you want an explanation
for them, see the playlist. Funnily, GLIDE was not
yet named like an offspring from DALL-E 1, because
they are architecturally so different.
But then April 2022, OpenAI decided to
go full in diffusion models and leave the
autoregressive legacy of DALL-E 1 behind
and released DALL-E 2, which is a modified
GLIDE model incorporating CLIP embeddings.
And now since August 2023, DALLE-3 became
available for just researchers and,
as of October, for a wider audience
through Bing Chat and ChatGPT Plus.
Its ideas are building on Latent Diffusion
Models, the architecture in Stable Diffusion
released August 2022 with researchers
from LMU Munich and Runway ML.
And now we will see what exactly
OpenAI has disclosed about DALL-E 3.
Well, not much about the architecture, since
it is a Latent Diffusion model based on a U-Net
and uses T5 XXL for encoding the text prompt,
but further technical changes are undisclosed.
But now the interesting training trick of DALL-E
3 that the authors describe is about its training
data. Because what was the problem of DALL-E 2?
It had troubles following the prompts exactly,
it misunderstands them or misses details. And
this is no wonder because the image-caption
datasets are scraped from the internet so they
contain images and their alt-text as caption.
Since me and you do not even remember when we last
wrote an extensive and descriptive alt-text, it is
no wonder that these captions are short, talk
mainly about the image subject but miss out on
details about the whole scene, the surroundings,
background and all the tiny details in it. So,
because the training data does not have lengthy
and detailed descriptions, the diffusion model
is bad at details because it was never exposed
to them. So the idea here for DALL-E 3 is to
take the existing images and generate such
lengthy and detailed captions synthetically
and then train the diffusion model on those.
But how to create these synthetic captions? Well,
by using an image captioner, basically
a transformer language model with CLIP
image embeddings as input. Image captioners
like this one are really good these days,
but it also reflects the training data for
short and undetailed captions, so it was still
reluctant to describe the details of the image.
So, the authors finetuned the captioner on a
small, human written set of elaborate and detailed
captions that describe many things in an image:
the subject in detail, then the background and
the whole scene, the colours that objects have,
the style of the picture, and so on. With
this image captioner, they recaptioned
the training dataset of DALL-E 3 and
trained it with 95% synthetic captions
and 5% actual captions written by humans.
And yes, the authors ablated between 80%,
90% and 95% synthetic captions and found that
95% gives the greatest similarity between real
captions and the generated image. But what about
98%? We do not see how this would play out.
This simple trick of synthetically
making the data better helped a lot,
because human annotators preferred DALL-E 3
over Midjourney and Stable Diffusion XL version
1 in the author’s human evaluation experiments.
The authors also show with Stable Diffusion-like
baseline models that a model trained on synthetic
captions still produces images similar to human
written captions, because here the blue line
of the model trained on synthetic captions
is not very far away from the yellow line of
a model trained on human generated captions,
when it comes to the similarity of the generated
image to the real caption. This similarity is
computed by the CLIP model by embedding the
generated image through CLIP’s visual branch
and embedding the caption through its text
branch. Therefore, it is called CLIP score.
Also, the model trained on synthetic captions
(blue line) increases the similarity between the
generated images and the synthetic captions,
which is expected by design of the training.
So yeah, this was the simple trick making
DALL-E 3 so good at following prompt
details and it was all about synthetic data.
The trick is so simple, no wonder that Google
Research published the same idea of synthetic
captioning just a few days after the OpenAI
paper came out. You can check it out, it is very
similar and even the experiments from Google
are on Stable Diffusion, just like OpenAI’s.
So, synthetic data looks like a good idea so far,
though we are wondering how far this can go
and whether the image captioner introduced
some peculiarities in the text prompts
that people could then eventually exploit.
After all, we have seen in a previous
video how with each step of training
a model on synthetic data, its distribution
gets skewed. And if repeated many many times,
it degrades catastrophically.
What do you think of OpenAI’s
technical report? Since they do not release what
else they innovated for DALL-E 3 other than the
recaptioning of the training dataset, I wonder why
they released this idea and not also the others?
Maybe they just wanted to release it before Google
Research was planning to? Anyway, if you want to
see more videos like this one, subscribe
to the channel. See you around! Okay, bye!